so it's early Monday morning and I've
been wanting to make a Monday morning
video for a long time but finally d-roc
we're doing it so real quick this is
just a rant very simple and something
that I want you to pass on or watch
every Monday morning because the level
of complaining is unacceptable look what
if I told you this was the last Monday
morning of your life what if I told you
you died this week would you complain
about your crap job or that test you
don't want to take I doubt it
you would go much higher level thinking
well that's really what it takes it
takes understanding that if you're not
pumped right now if you're begrudging
what you're about to do if you're if
you're not looking forward to it look I
respect practicality you got to go
through school because your parents want
to you got to pay your rent you got
screwed in loans I get it but please
recognize the world we're living in
we're living in a world where there's so
much more opportunity this internet
thing created way more opportunity for
all of us way more I mean look you might
not even be alive like your mom and dad
could have had sex like three minutes
later and you wouldn't even exist and
you're complaining you could have ended
up being a bus a tree I just don't get
the mentality of being head down sad on
a Monday morning I'm gonna make Monday
morning my [ __ ] I'm gonna make you
Saturday Monday morning that's what I
want to do every morning and that's what
I want from you please take a step back
and think about how awesome it actually
is and then recognize that you can
attack the world in a totally different
way because you were lucky enough to be
born during this era [ __ ] you Monday
your one big job